we have a very special guest in the
audience tonight you've got to give it
up Reed Richards of the Fantastic Four
is sitting in the crowd thank you thanks
I'm a big fan okay I'm glad you're a fan
and dr. Richards that's great I would
ask you please if you could not sit like
that all right it's not really cool is
there is there a problem Conan
yeah the theater has certain rules
anyone sitting in the balcony must have
their feet on the floor at all times
it's for your own safety and it wouldn't
be fair to everyone else you know well
guess what I'm complying with the rules
my feet are on the floor okay now that's
not what they make it out little hunk
down there can someone scratch my ankle
no no just leave him okay and of course
no one helping him you know you're
taking up a lot of room frankly it's
rude okay I don't hear anyone in the
theater complaining you know
please please please just pull your arms
and legs in okay please all right let's
move on we have an amazing show
that is that is not cool Reed Richards
well why do you assume it's me Reed
Richards everybody
you